after all these shots you said they were
they were like debriefed
did was there ever a record or was there
always a record of
potential civilian casualties with every
single one of these shots
no um in fact from what i can remember
um the collateral damage was never
mentioned
never not even thought of no it was it
was like yeah we got these individuals
the a funny thing here's a here's a fun
little funny story so pilots are very
particular i
as much as i hate especially fighter
pilots they're they're egocentric
personalities they've got a lot of
quirky traits
and one of the the funny things is is
that a pilot after
every action there has to be something
called an after-action report
and when i was in the when i first
joined the 15th reconnaissance squadron
we had so few people that
um usually it would be the same pilots
doing the shots more often than not and
they would write novels like it was like
watching someone writing the next script
for the next top gun it was like i was
in the seat and i was
doing this and and we were watching this
action happen and they would they would
go into so much detail
of things that were going on that
eventually
because leadership has to read every
report
they would be like keep the report to a
paragraph
you know six to eight sentences
that's it so and then it became after
after that order came down it went from
being everything reported as what's
going on to being like
you know not even complete sentences
it'd be like missile came off the rail
missile impacted missile uh
took out two individuals uh
that were labeled as high profiled
individuals
mission accomplished stuff like that so
it was it wasn't even like
uh i remember reading one report and the
pilot was like
i was sitting there drinking my coffee
and we got the
call from the jtac to power up our
missile like
it was just like this thriller that they
wanted to write right they wanted to be
a part of
i actually knew a pilot who got out and
went to hollywood
because he wanted to write uh he was so
inundated in the top gun world that he
wanted to write a top
script for really yeah that's
fascinating
i i'm actually curious about this new
top gun movie coming out because i hear
that there's uh drones
i didn't even know there was a new top
gun movie coming out supposed to come
out this year but it's coming out or
last year but it's supposed
it's coming out this year really yeah
top gun to
tom cruise and everything no they're not
doing tom cruise again are they yeah
yeah yeah really yeah if i ever had the
chance i would actually like to get a
conversation with that guy because
there's so many people in so many pilots
that just
referenced top gun and him and maverick
in the drones like they wanted to be
maverick like i have more respect for
iceman
because iceman was professional you know
it was
it was maverick's mistake that got goose
killed right
right and so and iceman was he's not a
bad guy he was just a
strictly disciplined dude you know and
uh so many of the pilots that were in
the drones were rejects because
but they felt because of that they felt
like they didn't belong in the normal
group
they were the maverick you know my
stalker
rick ryneerson wants to be maverick
he wants to be maverick in fact he calls
him he labels himself as jango
from jango and chain like he wants to be
django
like he has this idea of this
egocentric great personality that he
wants to be
but essentially they're just wannabes
yeah like we were talking about earlier
kind of gives them a story kind of gives
them some sort of meaning or purpose
right there was a i i could speak about
the
the military leadership and how they
were they're very poor
the military leadership that was in the
program they didn't fly
most of them were people that were
rejects from other squadrons
um about six months after my
first shot uh no wait january february
march april
five months after my first shot they did
something called a patch swap
which shoved majority of the people into
joint special operations command
but a lot of these people that were in
military leadership they didn't actually
do the job
they were trained to do it they would
come in they would do their currencies
once a month
and they would get flight pay and that's
a it was like basically
double their income and they wouldn't
even be flying and people like me
who we didn't get flight pay i was
flying i was probably flying
six days a week 12 hour shifts and
i never once got paid or compensated
you know and there are these people that
would fly who were in you know they'd go
to parties and they'd
do all these kinds of stuff if you were
part of the good old boys club you
didn't have to fly very much and you can
go and volunteer
and pad your enlisted performance report
and all sorts of stuff
they would totally discard what was
happening
overseas and what we were participating
in so they could be political
politically and socially set and that
was a really poor
environment and and a lot of the pi so
uh there was at one point a three-star
admiral came in and was like we want to
get the navy involved in this and send
you guys people to train up and
we want our own drones and i want to
talk to your leadership
about this and we sent them a captain
a staff sergeant and a senior airman and
the guy was like where are your enlisted
where are your senior leadership
where's your upper echelon leadership
and we're like
well these guys know the most they've
been in the program the longest since it
was in prototype and
the guy was like uh yeah this is
unsatisfactory went to the secretary of
defense and the secretary of the air
force and said we need to put
bodies higher enlisted and officers into
these positions
and so they sent out this missive to the
entire military that was like
we need people for the drone program
well
they didn't
no one joins the military to fly remote
controlled aircraft
right pilots don't join the military to
sit in a box
to fly remote control they want to be in
the air they want to be in their machine
and they want to feel it because it
[ __ ] gets them all
um and so the the
people who were responding to this were
like yeah this is a joke
they sent us all their rejects my
um my first
uh supervisor was a
cop reject because no one could [ __ ]
stand him
everyone hated him in his prior
squadron and so they sent them to us
and as a way well it's a cross-training
opportunity for you to expand your
military career
and to get promoted he ended up getting
master sergeant because of it
uh basically just giving it to him he
was a good tester but he was a terrible
human being
and you know most of the people were
like that the pilots that were given to
us were rejects from their squadrons
they couldn't make flight lead they
couldn't make flight command
they were one of the pilots that i was
uh that i loved to death was um
uh he was a b-52 guy and he would get
air sick
so because he couldn't stay in the air
they sent him to drones um there was
another pilot that i loved who
was my commander in iraq and he
the reason he wasn't he was an f-16
pilot and the reason he was no longer an
f-16 pilot was because his eyes were
and he didn't want to get out of the
military forced retirement so he became
a drone operator
right so we had a lot of these guys with
medical problems and behave there's a
couple
dudes with behavioral problems as well
they spend millions of dollars to train
these guys
and then they don't want to get rid of
them because if they kick them out of
the military these guys either go to
jail or spend
the rest of the lives [ __ ] oh
[Laughter]
my what happened your computer fell
yeah my little desk thing is oh oh
oh good lay down but you down lay down
lay down lay down lay down
um you know and uh they send
they just uh these guys that had
behavioral problems they
um after i i'll use an example for one
of them
uh this guy's when i
started blowing the whistle um a couple
years ago
his ex-girlfriend called me up and was
like
i need you to reach out to this dude
because one of the pilots that you were
with
is now like he's in jail he's drinking
he's gambling got gambling problems he's
no longer in he just [ __ ] lost it
like he got out and was like
he just lost his [ __ ] um one of the
women pilots that i was friends with
um when we were when we were flying like
we would
complain like her and i would be like
this [ __ ] sucks this is
you know she was a heavy pilot so she
she was a transport and she was like i
loved flying like that was my
dream and now i'm sitting here murdering
people
and hunting people down like this is a
nightmare and
at one point she was flying a training
mission
a local sortie and she rammed the
aircraft off the runway
she like had a mental breakdown at when
the aircraft was coming up the runway
didn't pull up and the aircraft just
went off the runway
right jeez so a lot of these people
would just they would just have
mental breakdowns because we weren't
getting we weren't
not getting the support that we needed